Un memo segreto del Cremlino è finito
nelle mani del quotidiano Bloomberg.
Dentro c'è scritto che la Russia, la
stessa Russia che da 4 anni urla al
mondo il dollaro è morto vuole tornare
nel sistema del dollaro e nessuno ne
parla come dovrebbe perché se questa
cosa è vera cambia tutto. cambia tutto
per i mercati, per loro, per chi ha
soldi investiti in qualsiasi cosa e
cambia soprattutto perché potrebbe
mettere in discussione la narrativa
dellaizzazione,
dei bricks che stanno costruendo un
mondo nuovo, dell'euro che si
rafforzerà, dell'oro che andrà sulla
Luna. Alla fine di questo video avrai
gli strumenti per capire cosa sta
davvero succedendo e soprattutto come
cominciare a proteggerti. Salve a tutti,
Marco Casario qui sono l'autore dei
quattro pilastri dell'indipendenza
finanziaria e come sempre facciamo
partiamo dai fatti. Bloomberg pubblica
un articolo basato su un memo interno
del Cremlino, un documento riservato che
è stato visionato dall'azienda stessa e
che è circolato tra gli alti funzionari
russi. Il memo porta il nome di Kiril
Dimitriv, negoziatore del Cremlino e
capo del fondo sovrano russo. Non è un
burocrate qualsiasi, è uno che capisce
profondamente le conseguenze finanziarie
di ogni mossa. E dentro questo documento
ci sono sette aree di cooperazione
economiche proposte agli Stati Uniti.
Sette. La prima aviazione civile. La
Russia propone contratti a lungo termine
per modernizzare la propria flotta
aerea, potenzialmente con la
partecipazione americana nella
produzione. La seconda, una joint
venture nel petrolio e nel gas naturale
liquefatto. Questo include perforazioni
offshores e giacimenti difficili da
raggiungere. E qui c'è un dettaglio che
fa drid drizzare le antenne. Il MEMO
suggerisce che le aziende americane
potrebbero recuperare le perdite passate
dagli investimenti congelati dopo le
sanzioni. Questo è un appello diretto
agli interessi corporativi americani e
Trump, ormai lo sappiamo, è molto
sensibile a questo tipo di musica. La
terza, trattamento preferenziale per le
aziende americane che vogliono rientrare
nel mercato russo. Dopo che i brand
occidentali sono usciti dalla Russia nel
2022, la porta potrebbe riaprirsi, ma
con condizioni speciali. Putin stesso ha
detto che i produttori nazionali avranno
la priorità, ma chi vuole tornare lo
potrà fare. Quarto punto, cooperazione
sull'energia nucleare. E qui il MO si
spinge oltre, parlando anche di
intelligenza artificiale, territorio
strategico, tecnologie che definiscono
chi dominerà i prossimi 30 anni. La
quinta è un vero e proprio terremoto, il
ritorno della Russia al sistema di
pagamento in dollari anche per le
transazioni energetiche. Tu pensa un
attimo a cosa significa questo. Il
prezzo dell'energia regolato in dollari
è uno dei pilastri del potere
finanziario americano. Se il petrolio e
il gas russi rientrano nei mercati in
dollari è una vittoria simbolica e
strutturale per Washington e Trump non
esiterebbe un secondo a rivendicarla.
Il sesto punto, cooperazione sulle
materie prime critiche. litio, rame,
nichel, platino. Questi sono i mattoni
dei veicoli elettrici, dei
semiconduttori dell'hardware militare.
Chi controlla queste catene di fornitura
controlla il futuro. Il settimo punto,
forse il più ideologicamente carico, una
spinta congiunta per i combustibili
fossili contro quella che il memo chiama
l'ideologia climate friendly, favorita
dall'Europa e dalla Cina. Signori e
signore, questa frase non è casuale,
sembra scritta apposta per fare leva
sugli istinti politici di Trump, sul suo
scetticismo verso i mandati Green, sulla
sua ostilità verso l'eolico, sulla sua
visione di dominanza energetica
tradizionale e la rete di donatori di
Trump è pesantemente concentrata
nell'industria dei combustibili fossili.
E adesso possiamo fare un passo indietro
e guardare il quadro completo. Questa è
la stessa Russia che negli ultimi 4 anni
ha costruito sistemi di pagamento
alternativi. La stessa Russia che ha
regolato il 90% del suo commercio con la
Cina in rubly e la stessa Russia che ha
guidato i bricks nel tentativo di porre
fine all'egemonia finanziaria americana
e adesso quella stessa Russia dietro le
quinte propone di tornare al dollaro. E
qui la domanda diventa perché. E per
capirlo bisogna guardare i numeri, non
le narrative. Il commercio tra Russia e
Cina vale circa 250 miliardi di dollari
l'anno. Sembra tanto, ma tutto sommato è
solo il 10-12% del PIL russo che si
agira intorno ai 2500 miliardi. La Cina
da sola non può salvare la Russia e c'è
di peggio. Quel commercio è in calo di
circa 6-7 punti percentuali nel 2025. Le
proiezioni indicano un ulteriore calo
nel 2026 e quindi la domanda ma il
sistema alternativo Rublo One funziona?
Sì, funziona, ma è costoso, è
inefficiente, è complicato e soprattutto
ha creato una dipendenza dalla Cina che
a Mosca non piace per niente perché
Pechino sta facendo di tutto per
diventare il regno centrale del mondo
intero e quella che doveva essere una
partnership tra pari sta iniziando a
sembrare meno un'alleanza e più un
guinzaglio. Il sistema basato sul
dollaro e sullo Swift resta il più
efficiente per commerciare a livello
globale. perché sia giusto, non perché
sia perfetto, ma perché dove tutti sono,
è il più economico, il più veloce, il
più liquido. Essere esclusi da quel
sistema ha un costo reale, non
ideologico. E poi c'è la guerra. Secondo
fti russe, la Russia ha subito più di
225.000 morti dall'inizio del conflitto
in Ucraina. 225.000 giovani uomini in
età lavorativa e le stime indipendenti
dicono che il numero reale è molto più
alto. Per un paese che ha già una crisi
demografica in corso, perdere centinaia
di migliaia di giovani non è solo una
tragedia umana, è un disastro economico
strutturale. E il presidente uccino
Zeleski ha confermato tutto. Ha detto
che l'intelligence Ukraina ha raccolto
informazioni su un massiccio accordo
economico bilaterale tra Russia e Stati
Uniti che corre in parallelo ai
negoziati di pace. La banca centrale
della Russia ha smentito, ha detto che
non sa di cosa stia parlando Bloomberg,
ma c'è un vecchio proverbio che dice:
"Non credere mai a nulla finché non
viene ufficialmente smentito". Bene,
adesso spostiamo un attimo lo sguardo
dall'altra parte dell'oceano, perché non
è solo la Russia che ha bisogno di
questo accordo, anche gli Stati Uniti ne
hanno bisogno e forse ne hanno bisogno
di più della Russia. A gennaio 2026 il
debito nazionale americano ha raggiunto
i 38,4 trilionar. I pagamenti netti di
interessi superano già i 1000 miliardi
di dollari l'anno, il 14% del bilancio
federale. E per la prima volta nella
storia moderna il governo americano
spende più per pagare gli interessi sul
debito che per mantenere il suo apparato
militare. Fermati un attimo su questa
frase. Per la prima volta nella storia
gli Stati Uniti pagano più interessi
sulla loro carta di credito che per la
loro difesa. Per il 2036 quegli
interessi arriveranno a 2,14 trilionar,
quasi il doppio del budget della difesa.
Il deficit federale è quasi al 6% del
PIL e le proiezioni lo vedono crescere
fino a raggiungere un rapporto debito su
prodotto interno lordo del 120%
superando qualsiasi record storico,
compreso quello del dopoguerra. Ma cosa
c'entra tutto questo con la Russia e il
dollaro? C'entra tutto. Rei Dalio,
mitico investitore fondatore dei
Bridgewater Associates, il più grande
fondo di investimento del mondo, ha
scritto un articolo proprio durante la
conferenza di sicurezza di Monaco. Ha
detto una cosa che va dritta al punto.
La forza finanziaria, cioè la capacità
di spendere più del rivale per più
tempo, è uno dei poteri più determinanti
che un paese possa avere. È la ragione
principale per cui gli Stati Uniti hanno
vinto la guerra fredda. Non fu solo
superiorità militare, fu la capacità di
sostenere simultaneamente
i cannoni e il burro. Forza militare e
benessere domestico allo stesso tempo.
Mosca non ci riuscì per 40 anni, ma
adesso quella capacità si sta erodendo.
L'arma che ha vinto la guerra fredda
viene consumata dal debito accumulato
durante i decenni di prosperità che
seguirono proprio quella vittoria. Lo
disse già lo storico Paul Kennedy, la
ricchezza è normalmente necessaria per
sostenere il potere militare e il potere
militare è normalmente necessario per
acquisire e proteggere la ricchezza. E
quando una superpotenza perde la
capacità di finanziare entrambe le cose
senza ricorrere alla stampa di moneta,
entra in quella che il reio chiama la
fase tardiva del ciclo monetario.
Stampa, svalutazione, ripeti. Ecco
perché gli Stati Uniti hanno bisogno che
la Russia torni nel sistema del dollaro,
non per generosità, per sopravvivenza
finanziaria. Ogni paese che torna a
regolare il commercio in dollari
rafforza la domanda globale di dollari e
più dollari il mondo vuole, più gli
Stati Uniti possono permettersi di
stamparne senza che il sistema collassi
velocemente. Essere la valuta di riserva
globale ti permette di condividere il
problema dell'inflazione col mondo
intero, non sono con il tuo popolo.
Questo è il privilegio esorbitante del
dollaro e quel privilegio sta scivolando
via e i numeri lo confermano. Il
commercio globale regolato in dollari è
passato dal 72% circa a livelli che
ormai sono sotto il 50%.
Laollarizzazione non è una teoria
astratta, è un processo in corso,
misurabile che sta accelerando. Ma se la
Russia torna al dollaro, quel processo
potrebbe subire un colpo non mortale, ma
significativo, perché la Russia è uno
dei principali esportatori di energia
del pianeta e se quell'energia torna ad
essere prezzata in dollari, il messaggio
al resto del mondo è chiaro. Il sistema
dollaro è ancora il centro di gravità.
Per Washington sarebbe anche un premio
geopolitico enorme, significherebbe
ridivos da Pechino o almeno indebolire
quel legame. I regolamenti tra Russia e
Cina in One sono esplosi dal 2022.
Invertire anche parzialmente quella
tendenza sarebbe un colpo diretto alla
strategia cinese di sfidare la dominanza
finanziaria americana. Però qui serve
onestà intellettuale. Né la Cina nella
Russia si fidano dell'Occidente.
Entrambi i paesi approcciano qualsiasi
partnership con gli Stati Uniti in modo
pragmatico. Lo abbiamo visto più volte.
L'idea che una transazione in dollari
possa davvero separare la Cina dalla
Russia sul piano strategico è un po'
un'illusione e Washington ha fatto più
di qualsiasi altro paese sulla Terra per
indebolire il suo stesso asset più
grande, il dollaro, trasformandolo in
un'arma. Ve lo ricordate quando nel 2022
hanno congelato 300 miliardi di dollari
di riserve della Banca Centrale Russa?
Questo ha mandato un messaggio che
nessun paese al mondo ha dimenticato,
cioè i tuoi soldi nel sistema del
dollaro non sono davvero i tuoi, possono
essere congelati con la firma di un
decreto e questo è il paradosso. Gli
Stati Uniti usano il dollaro come
un'arma e poi si stupiscono pure che gli
altri vogliano scappare da quel sistema.
Ecco perché hanno bisogno che quegli
stessi paesi tornino indietro. Ma adesso
cerchiamo un attimo di allargare ancora
il campo perché tutto questo non avviene
nel vuoto, avviene in un momento storico
molto preciso, avviene alla conferenza
di sicurezza di Monaco dove tre dei
leader più influenti del mondo hanno
detto essenzialmente la stessa cosa. Il
cancelliere tedesco Frederick Merz ha
aperto dichiarando che l'ordine mondiale
che esisteva da decenni non esiste più.
Macron ha chiuso la prima giornata
affermando che le vecchie strutture di
sicurezza europea sono scomparse e che
l'Europa dovrebbe prepararsi ad uno
scenario di guerra. Marco Rubio, che è
il segretario di Stato americano, ha
riconosciuto, prima ancora di atterrare
a Monaco, che il vecchio mondo se n'è
andato e che siamo in una nuova era
geopolitica. non è stata retorica, non è
stato allarmismo elettorale, è stata una
diagnosi condivisa da tre capitali che
raramente concordano su qualcosa. E
torniamo un attimo a Rei Davio che nei
suoi libri descrive cinque tipi di
guerra che possono esistere
contemporaneamente. Guerra commerciale
ed economica, cioè restrizioni
all'import. Gli Stati Uniti hanno
imposto tariffe crescenti dal 2018 e le
hanno intensificate nel 2025 con i
ricavi doganali americani che sono
aumentati del 292%
su base annua a novembre del 2025. La
guerra tecnologica, controlli sulle
esportazioni di semiconduttori verso la
Cina, restrizioni sulle piattaforme
digitali, corsa all'intelligenza
artificiale, guerra geopolitica, cioè
dispute su territori, alleanze, sfere di
influenza. L'Ucraina è l'esempio più
evidente, ma c'è Taiwan che è il più
pericoloso. La guerra di capitali,
sanzioni, congelamento di attivi, taglio
dell'accesso ai mercati finanziari.
Quello che è stato fatto alla Russia nel
2022 ha creato infatti un precedente.
Quinta forma di guerra, la guerra
militare vera e propria. Realiono nota
che storicamente le prime quattro forme
di guerra si intensificano per circa un
decennio prima che scoppi un conflitto
armato tra grandi potenze. Non sempre
accade, però il pattern è chiaro e
quattro di queste cinque guerre sono già
attive oggi. Ma adesso veniamo a noi e
parliamo di cosa significa tutto questo
per noi poveri risparmiatori e
investitori. Perché se sei arrivato fino
a questo punto del video vuoi sapere una
cosa sola: cosa faccio con i miei
risparmi e investimenti? C'è
un'osservazione che ho trovato potente
che voglio condividere qua in questo
video. In questo momento tutti gli asset
sembrano un po' correlati tra loro. Non
c'è più nulla che sia davvero
decorrelato e il motivo è semplice. Il
fattore che li tiene correlati è
l'incertezza. Gli investitori non sanno
come sarà il nuovo ordine mondiale.
Proprio quando pensi che l'oro sia il
posto giusto, ecco che l'oro scende
perché la Russia dice forse torniamo al
sistema del dollaro proprio quando pensi
che il dollaro sia spacciato, allora si
rafforza perché una potenza nucleare
vuole rientrare nel suo sistema. Proprio
quando pensi che le azioni tech siano il
futuro, queste tremano perché nessuno sa
se l'intelligenza artificiale è una
bolla o è la più grande trasformazione
della storia. Ai mercati non piace tutta
questa incertezza. mercati si bloccano,
si guardano intorno terrorizzati e poi
scattano in una direzione senza nessuna
logica apparente. Forse non è un caso
che Michael Barry, quello del grande
short, quello del 2008, ha liquidato il
suo intero gruppo di gestione
patrimoniale qualche mese fa e ha
restituito i soldi agli investitori
dicendo "Non li capisco più questi
mercati". Beh, il messaggio è un po'
chiaro, no? Siamo in un territorio
inesplorato. E ma allora cosa si fa?
Beh, primo, non si abbraccia nessuna
narrativa senza riserve, né quella di
Dio che dice: "Compra l'oro e vendi
tutto, vendi il debito perché le guerre
si finanziano stampando moneta". La sua
tesi sì, è coerente, ma il mercato
obbligazionario, che è il più grande e
sofisticato del mondo, non si sta
comportando come se credesse a questa
narrativa. I tassi a lungo termine non
si sono impennati. I grandi operatori
istituzionali che muovono trilioni ogni
giorno trattano ancora il debito
americano come un asset accettabile.
Questo non significa che Dio abbia
torto, significa che il suo consiglio è
una scommessa direzionale, non è una
verità assoluta. Secondo, bisogna capire
che gli Stati Uniti emettono debito
nella propria moneta, che resta la
valuta di riserva globale. Questo dà
loro una flessibilità che nessun altro
debitore del pianeta possiede. Possono
monetizzare il debito stampando dollari.
è una mossa con conseguenze sicuramente,
ma è un'opzione che un paese indebitato
in valuta straniera come noi Italia non
c'ha. Terzo, gran parte della crescita
della spesa americana è legata
all'invecchiamento della popolazione. La
spesa per la sicurezza sociale passerà
da 1,6 trilion a 2,7 trilion entro il
2036. I programmi sanitari
raddoppieranno. Questo è un problema
fiscale serio, ma non equivale al
collasso di un impero. È il costo di una
società che invecchia con uno stato
sociale sempre più esteso. Quarto, c'è
un'ipotesi che dobbiamo considerare.
Forse il disordine globale a cui stiamo
andando incontro non è una fase
transitoria verso un crollo. Forse è lo
stato permanente con cui le potenze
impareranno a condividere. Il mondo tra
il 1945 e il 1991. Sembrava ordinato, se
visto da Washington o da Mosca, ma era
caotico se lo vedevate dal Vietnam,
dall'Angola, dal Guatemala,
dall'Afghanistan. Quello che chiamiamo
ordine internazionale basato su regole
era in buona parte l'ordine che
conveniva a chi lo aveva progettato. Che
quel progetto specifico adesso si stia
erodendo non significa necessariamente
che arriverà il caos assoluto. può
significare che stiamo transitando verso
un sistema multipolare, più disordinato,
sì, ma comunque funzionale, come il
concerto d'Europa tra il 1815 e il 1914,
un secolo di rivalità intense ma senza
guerre generalizzate dalle grandi
potenze. E c'è un ultimo dettaglio che
merita attenzione. Lo ha dato Rabobank,
che è una grande banca olandese, e ha
fatto notare che il memo del Cremlino è
uscito esattamente nel momento in cui i
leader europei si riunivano per
discutere come aggirare la Russia
commercialmente e contemporaneamente la
Russia, eccola lì che propone un mega
accordo agli Stati Uniti tagliando fuori
l'Europa, potrebbe essere una mossa
geopolitica brillante indipendentemente
dalla veridicità del memo stesso. un
modo per dire all'Europa attenti perché
mentre voi discutete come isolarci, noi
stiamo già parlando con il vostro
alleato più grande e per dire agli Stati
Uniti vi offriamo quello che volete di
più, il ritorno al dollaro in cambio
della fine delle sanzioni e di un nuovo
rapporto. Qualunque sia la verità una
cosa è certa. Il fatto stesso che questa
proposta esista, vera o tattica che sia,
ci dice che la dollarizzazione non è il
percorso lineare e inevitabile che molti
ci raccontano. È un processo complesso,
pieno di inversioni, di calcoli, di
doppi giochi. E per chi investe il
messaggio è uno solo: non legarti a
nessuna narrativa. Non fidarti che il
dollaro crollerà. Non fidarti che il
dollaro dominerà per sempre, che l'oro
salverà tutto, che i bricks cambieranno
il mondo. La realtà è che siamo in un
momento in cui i modelli mentali con cui
abbiamo navigato i mercati negli ultimi
20-30 anni forse non funzioneranno più
come prima. E l'unica strategia che ha
senso sarà la diversificazione, ma
intelligente, la capacità di cambiare
posizione quando cambiano i segnali e la
disciplina di non farsi trascinare
dall'emozione del momento. Perché in un
mondo che ti chiede certezze ad ogni
passo, la cosa più onesta che puoi fare
è dire "Non lo so, ma ho gli strumenti
per adattarmi" e quella già è una
posizione di forza. Bene, se questo
video ti ha dato qualcosa su cui
riflettere, lasciami qui sotto un
commento, iscriviti al canale e mettimi
un like perché ne arriveranno altri di
video così. Grazie mille, buoni
investimenti a tutti. Co?